vial tuez pas nous faire geneviève de
fontenay comme je suis tellement content
d'être à côté de michel ouais je te
raconter une blague si tu veux avoir du
mal et geneviève oui oui là le jour
c'est complètement et cgt malgé et
humain j'ai envie d'aller à l'église
pour confesser gérant le curry ville
monsieur le curé je crois en rien du
tout mais je vais me confesser quand
même genre lève mon chapeau tu te dis
pas l'effort qu'il faut pour moi
d'enlever mon chat qu'il n'y a rien de
chaud où il reste aux deux cailloux mais
bon alors je rendrai effigie monsieur le
curé je voudrais vous dire un truc je
voudrais vous confesser que vous avez
fait quelque chose de mal j'ai vu où il
roule alors oui oui vous savez pendant
la guerre j'ai caché un juif dans la
cave aux usa c'est un acte héroïque
madame de fontenay ou devait être fier
de ça vous est ce qu'on appelle une
juste oui oui au fait je demander de
l'argent tu es moins j'ai demandé
l'équivalent de 500 euros par mois à peu
près eux mais oui mais ça c'est
formidable vous allez aller au paradis
madame de fontenay c'est formidable et
l'a donc elle lui dit le problème c'est
que j'ai toujours dit que la guerre
était finie
[Applaudissements]